If real, irrational, rational, whole and complex
numbers are the only numbers you’re familiar
with...boy have I got news for you.
Some special kinds of numbers, like quaternions
and octonions, describe more than our three
dimensions.
Just let that sink in a little bit.
Can you even picture the kind of math involved
for a reality that exists in more than 3D?
How would we even think about those shapes?
Let’s take it back to like, middle school
for a sec.
If you want to travel in one dimension, you
add and subtract real numbers.
Here you are, the dot, on your little line,
and you want to move 7 units to the right?
Great, that’s plus seven.
Let’s take it into two dimensions.
To make moves like this you can use what’s
called an imaginary number These can be combined
with real numbers to make what are called
complex numbers.
Real numbers and complex numbers are the first
two of four number systems in pure mathematics
that we call the normed division algebras
over the real numbers.
We can think of complex numbers as two-dimensional
numbers...because they help you move things
in 2D.
But something kinda funny happens when you
use these division algebras to manipulate
an object in 3-dimensions.Say you’ve got
a cube, and you need to be able to rotate
it around to see all its sides.
What kind of math are we looking at?
After the 1D real numbers and the 2D complex
numbers… comes a division algebra with 4-dimensions,
not 3, like you’d expect!
And this 4-dimensional number system is known
as the quaternions!
And they are awesome and SUPER crazy, so we
got in touch with Cohl Furey, a postdoctoral
researcher at Cambridge who lives and breathes
this stuff.
She helped us get a lot of this straight,
and if you’re a math PhD, you can go watch
her series on quaternions and get real nitty-gritty.
But for the rest of us--quaternions are the
number system we use to describe 3D shapes
in 4D space.
That sounds a little trippy, but that fourth
dimension doesn’t necessarily represent
a spatial dimension, like up and down.
Sometimes we use extra dimensions to represent
a different concept, like time.
So in your quaternion, you have a real number,
nested inside your complex number, and two
new terms, j and k, which represent your two
other dimensions--four components, hence the
‘quat’ in quaternion.
What makes quaternions extra hard to work
with is that they’re noncommutative.
Stick with me here--that means the order of
the calculations matters in a way it doesn’t
with real and complex numbers.
Think about it: If we go back to our 2D axis,
it doesn’t matter if you rotate in the plane
by 10 degrees first, and then by 20 degrees,
or 20 degrees first and then 10 degrees--either
way you end up in the same place.
But in 3D space, if we have our cube, it can
matter which move you do first, partly because
you have more options.
And while they may sound insane, quaternions
are super useful--they come in handy when
calculating the launch trajectory of an aerospace
vehicle.
Your phone can use them to calculate your
device’s position and orientation in space.
We use them all the time in generating computer
graphics and for programming robots, which
move around in 3D space.
They are also especially important because
a version of quaternions underpin Einstein’s
theory of special relativity--allowing us
to calculate the movement of an object in
3 physical dimensions, plus the extra dimension,
which can be defined as time.
But strap in--’cause here come the octonions.
That’s the next step up.
Now, because of some complex mathematical
rules, these kinds of numbers come only in
dimensions 1, 2, 4, and 8, so after quaternions,
we make the jump to octonions--numbers that
help us navigate eight-dimensions.
That’s the quaternion, which contains complex
numbers, which contain real numbers, plus
4 new units.
E1, e2, and e4 are one way that i, j, and
k from the quaternions are represented in
the octonion system.
These eight ‘dimensions’ again, don’t
have to be spatial--they can represent characteristics
of particle behavior, like how certain particles
behave under the strong force, making octonions
really useful for quantum calculations.
And there we have our nice neat set of the
four normed division algebras [over the reals]
[over the real numbers]
The thing is, with each next level, the math
of these division algebras gets even more
tangled.
Quaternions are noncommutative, and octonions
are too.
But they’re also nonassociative--which means
not only does order matter, but it also matters
how you group the multiplication of octonions.
But the very structure that makes the math
so difficult is one reason that the octonions
can be so useful in describing fundamental
physics.
One recent paper revealed that octonion mathematics
allows for the existence of sterile neutrinos--a
particle that scientists are actively looking
for experimentally because...it might be dark
matter.
That’s just one of a whole host of applications--many
of our models of particle physics are still
incomplete, but in the words of Dr. Furey
“...there have been a number of very tantalizing
hints that the octonions might somehow underlie
certain aspects of the structure of elementary
particle physics.”
So they’re famously difficult to work with.
But incredibly useful and underpin the forefront
of mathematical exploration happening today!
They’re so crazy physicists even disagree
on how to approach them, but researchers hope
octonions will help them peel back the layers
of reality to explain why the universe behaves
the way we observe it to.
Wow.
We made it through that, pretty exciting.
Now we know more about extra-dimensional math!
For more mind-blowing close-up looks at the
universe, check out this video here.
A huge thanks again to Dr. Cohl Furey for
helping us make sure this was all correct,
and let us know in the comments if you have
any questions or any other in-depth mathematics
that you’d like us to explore.
Thanks for watching!